oi meu nome é helena eu vou contar pra
vocês um pouco sobre uma pesquisa que eu
fiz sobre impacto da tecnologia na vida
das pessoas
na hora pensei na escola tem como a
gente aprende e depois na medicina
pensei que as pessoas aprendem mais
estiverem interessadas gostando do
processo
foi aí que eu comecei bom na primeira
pergunta foi o que meus amigos mas
gostam de aprender responderam que seus
interesses estavam entre matemática e
ciências
e que aquele as matérias em que achava
mais importantes era português e
matemática também perguntei como eles
gostam de aprender responderam que era
por meio de jogos e atividades no ipad
como por exemplo o manual do mundo para
ciências e ocana km para a matemática no
meio da minha pesquisa eu fui numa
empresa que trabalha com r a conhecida
também como realidade aumentada
realidade aumentada nada mais é do que
aplicativos do ipad que escaneiam livros
e mostra tudo de um jeito mais lúdico
também perguntei o que meus amigos
gostariam de aprender que a escola não
ensina responderam seus interesses e
também estavam em que com vivências e
assuntos mundiais também perguntei como
a escola poderia ser diferente
responderam que os professores poderiam
ser mais amigos dos alunos os
professores são exemplos de empate
colaboração com eles os alunos saem da
escola sabendo como enfrentar o mundo
através de blogs relacionamentos
se formos pensar em outro caso bem
importante da nossa vida a medicina o
caso é bem parecido
não sei se vocês conhecem o othon
computador que junta uma enormidade de
dados e assim pode dizer mais
precisamente a que cada pessoa tem bom
mas você já parou para pensar um
computador discutindo um longo
tratamento como de câncer ou mesmo um
computador aconselhando uma família
sobre os medos e ansiedades um contador
dizendo que existe uma doença grave e
uma criança
não dá pra imaginar assim como não dá
pra imaginar uma sala sem professores
tanto os médicos como os professores
podem se usar a tecnologia para ajudar
tornar suas atuações cada vez vez mais
efetivas mais um computador nunca
substituir as relações humanas ea cada
vez mais disse que nós precisamos
obrigada